the suspected Boston Marathon bombers
this CCTV footage put police on their
tracks in the rucksacks the brothers are
allegedly carrying the homemade
explosive devices that killed three
people it took investigators only a few
hours to identify the suspects from
these images since the success of the
search in Boston the debate on more
video surveillance has been revived
Germany's conservative interior minister
is in favour in diesel soot Watson was
in this situation it's not an
overreaction but an objective and normal
indication that we in Germany have to
improve and tough on our video
surveillance the opposition parties are
against this and even the free democrats
the junior partners in the governing
coalition rejected we need moderation
video surveillance in trouble spots and
dangerous places in Germany is right and
proper and possible but blanket
surveillance of all citizens would
create an information overload not more
security stat music ad but what do
ordinary Germans want more video
surveillance and railway stations and
public places select money if you've got
nothing to hide you have nothing to fear
from surveillance I think it's ok to
have more than there is now I think we
already have blankets video surveillance
and that's enough yes certain places
were lots of people gather for events as
we've just seen in Boston could have
better surveillance and our flesh become
quinta yeah short video surveillance in
public places be increased eighty-one
percent are in favor only eighteen
percent are opposed but it's clear even
the most stringent controls won't stop
potential attackers if they're really
determined
you